hey everyone it's sarah stanner sorry
and calm and today i'm going to
demonstrate how to find the popliteal
pulse point and whenever you're
assessing the pulse you will be looking
at a few things one thing will be the
rate how fast is it along with the
strength and you'll be grading it on a
scale zero to three with zero being
absent one plus it's week two plus it's
normal and three plus it's bounding and
then you'll want to look at the rhythm
is it regular or irregular and as you
fill on the pulse you will be feeling
bilaterally to see if they're equal and
this comes off the femoral artery and
it's located behind the knee in these
areas right here to find this pulse
point you're gonna flex the knee and
you're gonna take both your hands put
them behind the knee and you will find
it at about the middle area of the
popliteal fossa which is a diamond shape
hitted area behind the knee and this
artery is pretty deep so helping to bend
the knee will help you find that artery
okay so that wraps up this video on how
to check the popliteal pulse point and
don't forget to check out our other
videos on how to check the other pulse
points on the body thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos